who
is from across the bay he's the chair of
genetics Stanford and also one of the
leaders of the much mentioned today en
code project uh and he was to tell tell
us about variation regulatory
information within and between
species okay well thanks very much for
having me here um I'm in fact going to
cover several different topics uh one is
as advertised variation of regulatory
information amongst initially amongst
humans So within a species we'll to talk
about some of our recent work mapping
chomet and differences amongst people
and then also how some of this might
translate into differences in protein
levels um I want to tell a story about
master variators uh key genes that can
control whole entire
Pathways uh I want to talk about some
work then that comes out of the mouse
end code and end code project so
differences between mice and human why
is it we don't look like a mouse and
mice don't look like us and then I'll
talk a little bit about the end code
project and and function which has
gathered lots of interesting blogosphere
press and things like that lately so
that'll be be a fun way to end the talk
here all right so um we are interested
in this fundamental question as I think
many people in this room are uh what's
the difference between individuals and
between species and there's been as you
know uh proposals made a long time ago
by I guess initially Mary CLA King about
uh perhaps the biggest differences
between individuals and between closely
related species are is regulatory
information and then in the ues I uing
90s I would say during initially with
micro Ray and later with RNA seek
there's been lots of different
experiments to map differences in gene
expression uh using again micay and and
um uh now more recently RNC so
originally dermus and Barbara stranger
had some very nice studies and more
recently there's been in fact there's
even some more recent studies since this
mapping differences from Jonathan
Pritchard again also deraz zakus and
then similar kinds of Studies have been
carried out across species as well I've
just listed a few this is only examples
I know there are many many studies out
there okay so Kevin White for example
had some nice papers amongst primates
along with yov Gill and John Pritchard
and then this is more recently
translated into trying to understand the
differences in gene expression there can
be many uh possible Avenues by which um
you get RNA expression differences and
we were because our lab is very
interested in transcription Factor
binding and uh um and its relationship
to gene expression we got involved in
mapping differences initially amongst
different yeast species from our our
yeast work actually so we had our group
was one of the labs that invented what
was Chip Chip at the time now it's
morphed into chip SE seek and we mapped
lots of different binding sites lots of
different transcription factors one set
of uh projects we did was map
differences in binding sites among some
key uh factors involved in pseudo hyal
growth and mating amongst different
species and some of them were even very
close to one another like uh SAC visi
and mik and the net result was that they
were actually at the time that was quite
a surprise the The Binding site
differences were very different because
most people actually sequencing genomes
and trying to find the Align sequ es and
say aha these are uh you see all these
line sequences that's where the
regulatory information is but it's clear
when you actually measured binding there
were quite a bit of differences and from
three different yeast to which as I say
this is about the same distance as
chimps and humans uh based on sequence
um uh and this one's further away more
like mck and humans uh we found that
there's only about 20 to 25% finding
site conservation and then similar
studies around the same time from Duncan
Odum showed that uh similar differences
there's extensive differences between
mice and humans so this prompted us to
say well how much variation does occur
then within humans um and so we
initiated some experiments first with
Mike Kowski in the lab working with
Fabian kert M the Bing sites of NF Capa
B initially and Paul 2 in hat map cell
lines that have been sequen we did this
so we could actually map out how
sequence information was associated with
these variation and binding events but
what we found was that there's quite a
few it obviously depends on the
threshold but there's quite a few
binding sight differences between this
pretty key transcription Factor NF Capa
B and also Paul to and and a lot of
these were at incredibly interesting low
side so this was nice it showed that
there is quite a bit of regulatory
variation within humans but we were
curious uh about a lot of remaining
issues one is just uh what kinds of
elements differ so here I showed
transcription Factor binding sites and
then Jonathan Pritchard showed DNA's
hypers sensitive sites different we're
very curious um are there differences in
the kinds of elements so for example do
promoters vary more than enhancers or
repress regions and another related
question is can you get
interchangeability can an enhancer in
one person be a promoter in another or a
promoter become an enhancer can so can
regulatory elements actually switch the
types of elements they might become and
then uh more recently we also got
interested while you see all these
differences in gene expression and and
TF binding as you'll see and how how
much is this turn into differences in
protein
expression and so uh to get at these
first set of questions we actually m m
chromative marks across the species
these can be used for defining enhancers
and promoters and and things of that
sort and so Maya uh and a very talented
team of of individuals sopia K very long
last name fan grouper Judah zag and anel
Kali did was actually mapped these Kon
marks and specifically we ma the marks
in
uh that are in these boxes here that are
associated with very specific elements
uh in the human genome so for example we
map The Binding site of of H3 K4
trimethylation I know this it's kind of
like Immunology it turns into a world of
jargon of its own but um I'll try and
stay with with the elements they're
associated with but so this is a
promoter Mark h3k4 trimethylation here's
a variant that also is associated with
promoters this is a chromatin Mark
associated with Gene bodies pul two is
often with promoters a little bit with
Gene bodies enhancer marks are things
like this one K3 uh acetalation
monomethylation here's one that's for
active enhancers H3 k27 acetylation we
have repressive marks we mapped as well
along with several other very
interesting protein ctcf which has been
uh shown the reside at boundaries and
cohesive and um at the end of the day we
mapped um not all these marks in all
individuals but we mapped a lot of the
marks somewhere between 9 and 13
different his stone or these regulatory
marks across 19 different individuals so
uh number from Africa uban a number of
Europeans uh and several Asians and then
we also had gotten from the h GMP
project uh we got four son Bushman and
whose genome we went out and sequenced
quite deeply and you can actually get
access to that data I think this group
might be very interested in that um so
we sequenced them quite deeply and then
in total we had then 19 different
individuals fairly diverse geographical
locations and we map these various marks
and uh as indicated here one of the ubin
sets as a as a trio another of the
European sets as a trio meaning mother
father daughter so we map these as I say
across these
individuals and it's actually a pretty
good data set if you ask me because we
actually there a lot of sequencing here
there's 56 million reads that 100 base
paired in that's nice CU then you can
start mapping out specific finding and
things like that um so it's actually
these are quite high quality data sets
again I think group might be interested
in this and so what we looked for then
was to map out regions for where you
would find differences and uh and one
such region shown here um this is uh the
19 different individuals you can see
here's a a mark this is actually the
active enhancer Mark and it's pretty
constant uh at these two locations but
you can see here's a nice variable site
this one actually correlates a bit with
a a population specific meaning these
are the the Europeans there's a binding
site in Europeans and Asians and not so
much in the other groups and and also in
this particular case and I'll come to
this later we could actually associate
this with differences in in The Binding
site in The Motif for a transcription
Factor actually it's a member of the
nfab family and so uh we did this as I
say for a number of marks and then we
could total up and see uh which kind of
marks varied most and sort of a brief
summary of that's shown here uh
basically the enhancer marks turn out to
be the most variable uh and repressor
marks at some level in terms of absolute
terms terms of relative amounts because
there's a lot more repressive marks than
there are active marks uh they're
they're less variable overall but the
the enhancers turn out to be the most V
enhancer marks are more variable and
then promoters are next and others now
excuse me to look at this more
systematically what we did next was
actually to take all these marks and
group them in trying to define
chromosomal or genomic segments based on
segmentation analysis and I'm not sure
if that's been presented here may come
up at some point but you can take all
these different marks this is a um set
up initially by two groups in the enco
project manolis Kellis and also by um
Hill Noble's group they set up different
methods for segmenting the genome into
sort of functional groups the so-called
segmentation analysis and the IDE idea
is that you'll take these different
marks uh we could take all of our marks
or at least in this case I guess we just
took the ones that we had done across
all the same cell lines uh you get most
the information actually from these six
marks and you basically we used a a um
an algorithm developed by manolis Chrome
hmm that basically takes these and then
segments the genomes into categories
based on on the groupings that come out
from the so machine learning method and
as we applied it in this case we defined
15 so-called segments of the human
genome and they would be characterized
by the various marks that you see here
propensity for these different marks and
so for example this is an active TSS
Mark uh this actually is right next door
to it this is an active transcribe
region this is a weaker transcribe
region these are active enhancers these
are weak enhancers and so on so poised
uh promoters things like that Poise
enhancers you can Define the segments
based on the kinds of marks that are
here okay and so we then took that and
said well now that we have these genome
The genome classified in these subgroups
what kinds of elements are are varying
and once again the the information is
somewhat similar to the marks themselves
I guess not surprisingly that you will
find variable segments in the human
genome uh and then other regions that
are more constant and so this shows us
now with a segmentation kind of pattern
so I believe that um yeah green is a
gene body this is Gene body so here's a
region that's pretty um an active Gene I
should say that's pretty constant across
the 19 people but in this set of people
uh it's active in some but not in others
and then um there are promoter marks
like this one here red that's constant
variable over here so the point is that
this is a um a constant region and then
this is a pretty variable one and again
you can associate that with the marks
themselves but this really represents a
the um the classification of
That So based on that then we could ask
which of these marks are in fact the
most variable and this is one way of
plotting and I think I should have
grabbed a different one but it turns out
at the end of the day the enhancer marks
Pro to be the most variable so enhancers
are much more variable this is a a
relative scale and active enhancers um
are variable quite a bit and then
promoters are second so this is actually
a poised promoter um they're almost as
very as active enhancers or roughly the
same and then uh the promoters are are
more variable after that we supposed to
be able to see this yeah I'm not so sure
now what the I realize I grabbed not the
best slide for this sorry about that
that was me rushing around this morning
trying to I know I have a better one
that shows us better but may maybe I
could convince you better with this one
here on the marks where you see the
numbers changing more but you have to
normalize that this well this is
fraction I guess this one isn't so bad
so um yeah what were you going to
say I was just
asking rela to the standard this is the
the more variable one jumping up this is
a variability index if you will this
one's higher than than a baseline for
how that was normalized and you're going
to ask me the details that I won't
remember them which is unfortunate so uh
okay sorry yeah all
right uh so the bottom line though it is
that enhances more variable I'll come
back to this a little bit you'll see
some other I hope I can convince you by
the end of this one of the things that
interest me a lot and and this because
we do this sort of stuff is a lot of the
marks between enhancers and promoters
are very very similar to one another and
so going into the study I was of the
guess if you will that you would see
enhancers and promoters interchanging
between one another uh between different
individuals that if an enhancer was no
longer enhancer perhaps could become
promoter vice versa and there's a way of
actually looking at this where you can
look at the the relative variability of
of changing between um uh one individual
uh sorry elements from one individual to
another and so this is if you will
conversion plot where where um Brown
means there's a greater chance of things
switching States if you will from an
enhancer state in this case uh look at
this dark brown one here this is an
active enhancer that switches into a
repressed region it's a polycom
repressed region and it turns out these
are some of the most variable ones in
the genome but when you look at things
like enhancers active enhancers turning
into active promoters that would be this
box here that actually almost never
happens that is a say we don't see
changes between uh States in in terms of
uh types of elements so enhancers and
promoters rarely inter convert and um
likewise um uh um some of the other
elements don't intercon convert but the
things that do convert a lot are
activity so you'll see active regions
turning into repressed regions that does
happen a lot or let me see if I can find
another one yes so this is the polycom
it is symmetrical so uh these are
polycom repressed regions these are
various enhancers they tend to get
turned off I think there's a promoter
one yeah here you see the promoter one
tends to switch off so activity States
change a lot but the types of elements
don't change if that makes sense so that
was quite interesting to me when
thinking about it evolving new enhancers
and
such now one question is how much of
this um is heritable and because we had
the tri as we had the mother father
daughter we could see how often uh the
child inherited the state from the
mother uh and the father and the answer
is actually a fair amount of it is
inheritable this is now plotted back as
the from it to Marks rather than States
although the results will be somewhat
similar for States um and the bottom
line is there's decent amount of
correlation if you will between the
children's marks and that of the
parents okay oops wrong direction and
then we can actually even go one step
further we can correlate how often these
marks are associated with variability in
a motif for a transcription Factor
binding site and the answer is actually
quite a few of them so these are the
number of regions if you will uh that
are significantly disrupted By changes
in one in the motif for one of these
more binding sites so this is an
association test not causitive but
you'll see a change in one of these
binding sites for Motif and then you can
ask how often it's correlated and the
answer is actually quite a bit so we
think actually there's a lot of genetic
uh basis that's responsible for some of
these chromatin State changes and there
are other sorts of analysis we've done
as well so the other yeah
a couple of questions one is about the
genetic basis I wonder if you went back
to look at the you know because we know
there's not many high
FST things on the sequence level between
these populations whe whether these
things that are different are actually
differentiated between the population
yeah that's a great question we could
actually
find uh quite a few that are that seem
to be correlated with populations but um
what is quite a few it's it's uh I
believe it's about a thousand sites
throughout the genome out of many tens
of thousands of things that we map so
it's a decent number that do seem to be
associated with specific populations we
did exactly what you said correlated
with the fs
patterns the other thing that comes up a
lot is well these are just Willy nearly
varying sites and maybe they don't have
anything to do with function maybe these
are nonfunctional sites so they just
drift around and certainly that is a
possibility but we did actually uh go
ahead and make a correlation between
variability and RNA expression as
measured by RNA SE so we me we did R
seek analysis in all 19 individuals and
uh actually you do see a pretty strong
correlation if you will uh between say
enhancers uh we've done this for promo
as well and RNA expression and in fact
um so it does when you have a variable
site that showing variable activity it
will also show um variable expression
okay one of the interesting things was
that uh we can show that if you had
multiple sites for enhancers varying you
would actually have a much much greater
chance of showing variability than with
gene expression and single enhancer
changes they were they were less
correlative that's not shown here the
other thing we could do is actually
associate to get a function um we could
look at variability and see whether
they're enriched for various interesting
um markers so for example eqtls markers
of gene expression we could show for
example here's an active enhancer Mark
and they're enriched for these segments
are enriched for eqtls but normalize to
several kinds of genomic backgrounds and
likewise gasit tend to be lying Within
These variable segments as well yeah
sorry this is a computer scientist
question but are the locations of
enhancers and promoters on the genome
different enough that that would explain
why they don't M each other I mean uh
why they're what
why they don't an enhancer does not
change into a promoter or vice versa um
are they Upstream of Gene different
amounts or are they the same well they
can be but there are plenty of enhancers
that'll only be a few kba away so I
guess I did Envision that they might um
convert and then you get an alternative
five Prime end or something like that
that's kind of what I was envisioning
might happen but that just doesn't
happen much yeah it's a great question
though okay and then these are the DNA's
hypers sens sites of CH and pritur and
they're also en Rich for some of these
marks as well all right so the bottom
line is we actually think there is a lot
of variability especially in enhancers
again at some of those marks you'll see
over a third of the enhancers tens of
thousands will vary uh across the human
genome so we think this does account for
quite a bit of variation in gene
expression so we know the gene
expression varies we know that
transcription Factor binding varies how
much of this translates into protein
this is actually uh a challenging set of
studies to carry out we actually
measured protein levels relative protein
levels across 90 of these hat map cell
Lines by mass spectrometry and a method
called TMT labeling I'm not sure this
crowd follows this sort of thing but
basically that involves putting Mass
Spec tags on uh five experimental and
one reference sample and then for every
protein you can measure which is
typically about 4 to 5,000
it depends on the experiment in this
case we can follow almost 6,000 proteins
uh you can follow relative amounts
across these cell lines for individual
proteins and I won't get into the
details more than that you what these
cell lines are like what oh I'm sorry
these are the Hat map cell lines the
lymphoblastoid lines that have been
sequenced yeah so these are mostly I
think about 60 of them as I recall were
your um sorry these are mostly Seth
lines um and then some of them were your
rubans I think uh and then there were a
few Asian lines sprinkled in as well so
it's mostly European which if you ever
do this again we've now almost entirely
switched to ubons because the original
Seth lines have been cultur longer and
they have more probably culture
variability associated with them but you
can still extract useful information but
it's just harder how much do I mean how
much do they get messed up in the
process of keeping them how much do they
have to do to them to well um I mean we
always go back to excuse me a fresh
fresh batch but
um they were propagated for a while
before they got stored and distributed
that's really where the the fundamental
problem is it's not us propagating them
further in the lab so they've been run
through many generations before they got
stored properly and distributed so it
and how many is then I don't know but
it's quite a few so the uban lines
you'll see if you ever correlate kids
for any of these experiments with
parents the in the eurs the correlation
is always tighter than it is for the
Europeans bit of a technical note there
that's true for every study we've now
done ribos seek on these lines and we
see the same sorts of things so all
right so anyway we measure relative
protein levels there's all kinds of
technical issues associated with this
and we look for first of all how many
proteins vary and the answer is it's
this is the number we Quantified um we
do these I should say at least um three
typically biological replicates
sometimes as many seven we do quite a
few because the the protein variability
technically is higher than it is for RNA
so uh you have a higher CV higher
variance and we would say about 6% of
proteins vary this amount or more which
is substantially lower than you would
find by RDC uh even on the same line so
we think variation in protein is less
than it is at the level of RNA and this
has now been this is done by relative
amounts we can it's not perfect but we
can use label-free methods to quantify
things by uh um more absolute terms and
uh we still see the same result that is
to say protein levels in general are
varying less than RNA so we think there
is buffering between RNA variation and
and final protein levels the other thing
we could do with this because we measure
all these these levels is we can M um
pqtl
so uh you know low side that control the
level of proteins and this is done with
U I should say this is all done by lyong
wo working with Sophie kellian in w
tangs lab and so what we do is we can
map you can set your threshold so at a
lower false Discovery rate you get this
many with a higher one which I know is
high but you got many more um and you
can then map these various regions
across um these
pqtls and one of the things that's of
interest is is how often is a Locus to
control gene expression also controlling
protein levels and vice versa okay half
of that question is easy to answer the
other half's tough and the answer is
half of the lows side that control
protein levels are also mapping on to
those that control RNA levels so
presumably those proteins are controlled
at the level of transcription and they
almost always map when you drill into
the fine structure near promoters near
five Prime ends if that makes sense but
the other part that to me was quite
interesting is course the other half
half of the things that are controlling
protein levels don't map to RNs
and so they must be due to other things
and in fact this is one example here
this is an interesting protein impa one
that's been implicated in uh certain
diseases and if we map out where the
lead Snips are in a more fed structure
analysis they tend to clusters the five
Prime ends here uh and they' be lower
there but the lead the lead Snips
associated with this are actually
mapping closer to the three prime end
and in one case we can actually drill it
to what we think is a um actually an
Exxon sequence as well so that one may
be affecting RNA uh and its particular
isopor so the point is that we can
actually find nul Loi that are
controlling protein levels that are
independent of of DNA levels or sorry
that are independent of expression
levels and to us this very interesting
because what we're trying to do for big
part of aab is trying to annotate the
human genome not going to go into this
in detail here but we're trying to
actually determine as many low sides
possible that are associated with
function because what we do is we take a
genome sequence and try and annotate it
with these pqtls now along with eqtls
and and binding qtls to try and figure
out which variants most likely to affect
gene expression and function or in this
case protein levels and function but the
ultimate goal of as I say trying to
annotate genomes so if we were to
sequence your genome we would be able to
say aha that variant is associated with
a low level protein and that may be
relevant to you okay I'm not going to
talk about that further today all right
the other thing I can say about those
protein um variation part is that we do
see classes of proteins that co-vary uh
and it is somewhat intuitive but it's
also nice to see so for example here's a
complex that a helic case that's been
implicated in DNA replication a lot of
translational uh types of proteins that
uh they they very in clusters and in the
same direction typically that is to say
if the level of one of these varies
amongst individuals they all tend to
vary okay and so we've we've mapped out
some of that so that is in fact um where
we are with the human work now one area
that's really lacking in all this is how
do these variants associate with
function and so we are trying some new
technologies to map this out in humans
but we've done quite a bit of work on
this in yeast and I want to tell you
about one story that I guess was now
just come out and this is the idea of
trying to map out phenotypic traits
associated with genetic programs uh in
this case in in different individual
strains of yeast so this is a
personalized yeast study if you will so
five yeast we took five actually more
than that but for this purpose of the
slide five East trains run them on all
kinds of different challenges different
growth conditions different drugs and
what you're supposed to appreciate out
of this is that these are five different
individual variants almost like five
different very diverse groups and they
um uh give very different uh growth
phenotypes on the different strain so no
one yeast strain just like many people
no one yeast strain is similar to the
other one thing that really caught her
eye was in fact this phenotype
nqo uh where this strain was incredibly
resistant this actually is a medical
isolate strain and this one was
incredibly sensitive so this is a very
drastic change in these two strains and
so Jen Gallagher who's the one who did
this work decided to pursue this and
drill in further so lar stat have taken
these two strains and made a bunch of
segregants actually several hundred and
then actually ma them down to uh very
very fine resolution to see what progyny
made a whole bunch of progyny
f1s uh and looked at which which
variation what sequences are associated
with progyny and so we use that we could
score this phenotype if if you will um
across actually we 125 different yeast
strains and what worked out pretty
nicely how of this is that we actually
found the number of low side many of
which are statistically significant but
there was one lowai in particular that
just jumped right out of us through the
roof here so there's this if you will
qtl associated with nql resistance you
can see strong resistance very sensitive
uh cant Etc so it's pretty easy to map
this one out and in fact because we had
so many segregants you could in fact map
it right not only to a gene but even to
a segment of a gene they map to this
Gene y
rr1 well y R1 it turns out was a rather
poorly characterized transcription
factor it's um had been implicated in in
mitochondrial function and other things
but it really it's not really clear and
still isn't 100% clear what it does well
we know better but it still isn't uh
super well characterized and so uh what
was interesting is that for this there's
almost no variation in The
Binding uh site for in the transcription
Factor binding region the DNA binding
region of this transcription Factor but
most of the significant variant were
then down at another region all the way
down here and I won't show you the data
for this but there is in fact a little
bit of an effect associated with the
promoter um but there's uh a lot more
effect associated with these so in fact
we can change um I believe it's this Al
here this this Lucine um to a Serene and
actually so these are the
non-conservative changes here but this
one turns out to be one of the more
potent ones if you change that Lucine to
a sering you actually will convert
you'll see in a minute nql resistance so
in fact we think a lot of the key
residues for controlling differences of
phenotype are not DNA binding they're
actually at the other end of the
molecule which is associated with
activation and or partner
binding so we did the obvious
experiments which is we swap the Le so
you have two strains of yeast going to
see if it really is the Y one Gene and
what amino acids are there and what we
discovered is so again this is the
resistance strain that's a sensitive one
if you take the sensitive strain and you
put in the resistant Al just as a uh you
actually confer
resistance the reciprocal is 100% true
that is to say if you take the
resistance strain delete the Gene and
put in the sensitive Al you still some
resistance and that's because of the
other lowai that are probably there
right there's some other resistance
lowai one of the things that was
incredibly interesting out of the cell
was we just because we knew the
phenotypes we looked at this a little
bit further but every time we swapped
this Gene for that strain uh this Gene
grows sorry this strain grows less well
on glycerol and if you add this Al to
that it also grows less well on glycerol
than this alil so the bottom line is
when whenever you have the this s96 alil
you grow better on glycerol but you're
ano sensitive if you have this Alo
you're Eno resistant but you don't grow
as well in glycerol so the two Al cause
different
phenotypes so we could actually map that
out to a single amino acid as they say
and then we took this one step further
summarizing a lot of results here but we
could actually do chipseek experiments
with the two different factors and two
different Al then later and this
complicated slide but these are five
different strains and what and we it's a
lot of work actually they did biological
Jennifer did biological replicates for
every one of these conditions we tested
three conditions five strains and then
also with the independent leals and
what's special about all this work is
that if you look at what's been reported
so far with variation and transcription
factors like David kingy work or others
typically what will happen is one strain
will have an active factor and the other
will have a mutant Factor trans so one
strain's on the other one's off what's
special about this case again this will
probably fry your neurons a little bit
I'll walk you through this um well let's
look at this one um here's a case where
this strain binds the the factor binds
well at this particular Locus and
glycerol The Strain doesn't bind at all
in those conditions but it'll show nice
binding for example in
nqo uh whereas this train shows very
less
binding so why is significant well there
are some low sign common so don't get
this all wrong but what's happening is
this factor is choosing two different
sets of Targets in the different strains
so it's not a loss of function it's an
alter it's a change of function okay and
and it's not just affecting one gene
it's affecting lots of genes because
there are a lot of lowai that will vary
then between in fact it depends what you
put your threshold but tens of lowai
will vary between this so we're calling
these and you'll hate this but that's
okay um Master
variators uh and the idea is that a
change we can map this to a single site
actually confers a whole new phenotype
and is a way of getting a whole new
developmental program if you will or in
this case a cellular program uh by by
just changing uh residue and we think
although that's been hard to show we
spent a lot of time on us trying to
figure out it's probably due to partner
swapping because it has different
factors associated with it we're having
a hard time figureing out what's what's
the direct one but it's not the DNA B
domain it's not like you're changing new
societ you're actually choosing who you
work with and given that most of the
transcription factors work with you know
many other partners it's quite logical
that if you start swapping your partners
you will get different phenotypes
probably not unlike people as well when
we swap our partners we not always the
same okay so uh that's our Master
variator story okay so we like these
because these are if you think about
they're they're a simple change can
actually turn on a whole new program
which we think is pretty interesting all
right um so okay so it's not in the the
piece of appr that's interacting
directly with the DNA right but um did
you try looking at the DNA anyway to see
if maybe variations of the DNA influence
what partner is there and then you know
so different region of DNA are different
partners and so then change which
Partners you like to hang out with you
can pick up the signal yes we do know
there are varying CIS sites that will
affect The Binding of that factor as
well and I wouldn't say we have
Associated those with different partners
you're suggesting a very interesting
idea could we use that to try we we've
tried to map out some of the partners
based on
coassociation and then we tried a lot to
do massp pull Downs in the different
strains as who here there and to be
honest the thing that's popping out the
most is the chromatin modification
difference so we actually think it may
be more through the
chromatin than and that may have then be
one of the chromat of modifying enzymes
rather than DNA and because they're more
indirect they're a little harder to map
so that's our guess but you know maybe
we're just missing a key transcription
fact because we haven't pinned it down
spite a lot of effort so but you're
raising well several good points
actually okay all right so that's what I
wanted to say about variation within a
species now um what time was I supposed
to wrap when do you want me to wrap five
minutes
yes all right so I'll tell you uh some
quick stories some of you will say we
got a little wrong and some of you say
of course I knew this already for this
next story so what's the difference
between mice and humans okay I can tell
you because that's what we got from our
reviews um all right so if you read the
literature uh not so long
ago uh there several groups Ben blenco
Chris Burge have mapped across multiple
species they map RNA expression using RN
data and they came to conclusion limited
number of tissues but these are examples
they what they found was that in fact um
the gene expression results clustered by
tissue uh but they saw tremendous
diversity in splicing isopor they said
all right gene expression across tissues
is pretty similar across species but uh
splicing variation varies a lot that was
a conclusion so published you a little
over a year
ago so as part of the mouse end code
project there are now and you can have
access to this it's about um
1100 uh he throughput experiments of RN
seek plus um transcription Factor
binding and we took a lot of these R
seek data and asked well same thing
let's take all of the gene expression
data from Mouse and human and just
cluster it up and see what happens so if
we would have believed the other
people's results they should have
clustered by tissues and the answer is
here they did not these are data from
different Labs circles are human data
sets and these funny looking party hats
are Mouse data sets okay and what
happened is that this is PCA anal 14
tissues or four Labs involved and this
and they clustered like this so we
thought well maybe um this isn't right
maybe because we had different Labs
involved we these are due to technical
reasons so basically irab went in and
repeated the whole experiment first with
10 tissues that's what you're now with I
think it's 13 or 14 again and the
results the same let me see if I guess I
cirle them actually the um the the gene
expression on the whole and you can do
this by several different algorithms and
it generally comes out the same not
exactly the same but generally pretty
similar so what's happening is that
these tissues are clustering by organism
so by species not by tissue layers have
the same color those are yeah so that's
test that's the one one that's out there
yeah so
that's yeah and so I left that out of
the circle because I didn't know how to
deal with it but um and and that is the
most Divergent of the Munch so um and
we've now done as I say 13 this is just
the first results of 10 and the results
are identical okay so then the question
is why did we get our results and the
other people got their results and so
we'd spent a lot of time trying to
figure this out it wasn't the ortholog
list I should say this is just using
orthologue data from Mouse and human um
and it wasn't um the parameters we we
ultimately got their data and were able
to reproduce their result it's just that
they had chosen the most Divergent
tissue so brain
testes uh it was muscle and liver as I
recall and that's why they were
separated but if you actually choose a
lot more tissues they really don't show
so
separated and of course you can then
drill in deeper and you can say well
what are the genes that are causing all
this questioning by species right what
what are the genes in common that are
driving the human want to be human and
the mouse want to be Mouse and the
answer is it's a lot of metabolic genes
which you might expect because the
metabolism of mouse is very different
from a human that has 600 heartbeats per
minute human is 70 maybe 80 if you're
giving a talk or 60 L down but the point
is it's a lot of metabolic genes and
cell cycle genes and and uh this is not
the entire list but it's a lot of the
lists from the top so um it's these sort
of uh housekeeping types of things so
you can then and it's about 2700 genes
that drive this 2400 for human so then
you can pull those out and say well now
do they cluster and of course they do if
you pull out the species specific chams
uh I didn't Circle these but you can see
the circles and the colors are now
clustered rather than the circles and
the party hats so um the bottom line is
then you get back the tissue clustering
so what this means overall is that in
fact um a mount Mouse tissue is closer
to a mouse kidney is closer to a mouse
liver than a human uh kidney and vice
versa so some of you will say of course
metabolism El is different and I don't
that may be some of you say you got it
all wrong because published literature
says the opposite we've looked at this
so many ways I'm quite convinced this is
right but if you think about this makes
a lot of sense that um you know again
the metabolism of mouse is not the same
as a human so I think I've ran out of
time I was just going to say there's a
lot of Divergence in transcription
Factor binding sites I can tell you this
one result but so most like yeast most
differences that there's more Bing sites
that differ than are conserved if you
map them by
chipseek but what's kind of cool is
there's a conserved set and you take
that conserv set and you're going to ask
what's special about them well it turns
out they tend to be pleotropic they tend
to work in either multiple tissues or
have multiple partners that's what this
is shown these are a bunch of concerned
factors and they actually get Express
multiple tissues it's probably not even
the same family member that's always
binding in these cases but it's everyone
so we actually think a lot of what's
driving conserved binding is in fact
these enhancers and that's intuitive are
things with multiple
functions and now I going to get to the
um issue about end code and similarities
and differences we can say that well
I'll tell you there there there's a lot
of effort these days to try and
understand the as part of the enco
project to understand the relationship
between biochemical activity which is
what enco measures and evolution and
I'll uh see if I can summarize that here
but the bottom line is uh biochemical
activity measure lots of biochemical
activity through the genome uh and so
for example if you count everything you
can measure it's like 80% that's where
that 80% number come from you may have
followed this controversy so we would
say people could say it's 80% of the
genome is active that's true I don't
think 80% of the genome is functional
and that's what the Press head and
that's actually what I think caused all
the problems uh but then the question is
how much is active and it's a very
interesting question it's hard to say
but a lot of the genome is expressed as
RNA what I think is pretty cool is this
is what interests me a lot if you ask
how much is touching transcription
factor it's just the motif or DNH
footprint it's over 10% it's a lot of
the genome is in physical contact with
proteins and then you can actually
correlate um the strength of the signal
of a biochemical signal with its
likelihood to be conserved if you will
so this is encode signal strength for
say RNA and this is a number that are
conserved and the bottom line is it
tends to be the stronger signals are
conserved and the weaker ones less I
think again that's intuitive so that's
some new data come out of encode happy
to thre that out there so in conclusion
am out of time a lot of variation
between individuals a lot of variation
between species at the regulatory level
uh and we think um this will be
interesting pursue we love the idea that
this is responsible for a lot of
phenotypic differences and and in yeast
we can show that at least in some cases
from some of the studies I mentioned
just to tell you people excuse me people
did the work Mike Kowski and uh a very
talented group did the TF and and
chromatin variation then fanglu on the
protein variation Jen Gallagher on the
master variator story and the gene
expression studies were done by shinin
and his brother Yingling and then Ross
Hardison was a key collaborator in that
as well so happy to take any questions
but maybe I used up all my time so I can
decide what you're G to
do are there any more questions for
M yeah P STI variation we have very
detailed models for patterns of
polymorphism patters Divergence and we
kind quantify is there any hope of
getting quantitative models Divergence
within between species for this kind of
expression
variation you mean in step wise Fashions
sorry I missed the first part of what
you're saying well we have a sort of
neutral null model right variation and
you know there's a few parameters and
you can do all sorts of fancy mass and
stuff but is this do you think you'll be
able to ever quantify expression
variation in the same kind of way using
contic models for examp um I think so
because we're now I mean people are
spending a lot of time trying to build
models and the easiest one is between
say chromatin marks and gene expression
and then now you can actually do a
decent job but not as good as chromatin
with even a lot of TF binding uh and
gene expression so you make those
correlations and then the question is
which we're doing now is some of the you
know perturbations when you have a
variations variable site how does it
affect un expression and for some of the
simpler genes simpler meaning fewer
regulatory elements that we've
associated with them we actually can do
we think okay but uh I think what we're
trying to do now is model in the because
most genes really do have multiple
enhancers especially multicellular
organism so we're trying to model that
in as well so I hope the answer is yes I
think we should be able to make
quantitative models and I think the
other thing that will be very helpful
and we're generating a lot of this and
this will come out of uh the next phase
the enco project is these 3D interaction
Maps so where you can actually we've
done a lot of what's called chipet where
you can map actually promoters with
their enhancers and I'm hopeful that
that will help a lot to make sure we
properly assign who belongs to who the
way a lot of this is done now as you
probably know is correlative based on
activity and and that really bothers me
because uh these factors they do uh
differentially associate with different
Gene targets and so the idea that you
build them the assignment by correlation
is actually the opposite of the way you
really want to do it in my opinion if
that makes any sense yeah you found a
lot of variations are there any
unexpectedly constant relationships
between the species and you think of the
very complex biological machine surely
that must be something
precise yeah um that's a great question
so we looked at certainly when you look
at the types of genes That Vary the
immune response genes vary a lot even in
and above the fact that these are uh
lymphoblastoid lines uh we looked at
which ones vary the least and to be
honest I don't remember getting excited
about it because I can't even remember
the result but um maybe it wasn't
interesting one person's garbage another
person's gold
so I'm not sure the answer to that so
you got me thinking about it again
though yeah I have a technical question
the PCA you showed for Mouse and human
for uh s tissues did you did you run PCA
on the entire data for both Mouse and
human we ran on the first we generated
an orthologue list the best one it was a
team of people trying decide what was
the best Mouse human orthologue list so
we ran it we did run all genes but at
the end the one that counts as one just
looking expression where the where there
are what we think are well- defined
orthologues uh and we've used several
different orthologue lists it doesn't
matter which list we've gotten either
previous published ones or the new ones
we built the results always the same
so yeah okay well thanks thank
you